[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصادي الليله معكم عبد القادر
العياط في الوقت الذي احدثك فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
البدايه من جيبوتي ومنها نتابع مباشره
جلسه مغلقه ضمه رؤسائها ليجاد لبحث خريطه
طريق خاصه بدول الايجاد حول الازمه في
السودان
ثم الى البيت الابيض ومنه نتابع هذه الصور
بعد ان ابلغت الحكومه الاسرائيليه اداره
بعيدا انها تعتزم الاعلان في وقت لاحق هذا
الشهر عن بناء وضع خطط لالاف الوحدات
السكنيه الجديده في المستوطنات بالضفه
الغربيه المعتله
ثم الى ميامي الامريكيه وتحديدا من منتجع
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
استعدادات وترقب عشيه متولي ترامب امام
المحكمه وسط دعوات للحشد والحشد المضاد
بين مناصره ومناهضه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
اشتباكات في احياء متفرقه بالخرطوم
وانفجارات في ام درمان المفوضيه الافريقيه
تحذر من ان ازمه السودان تهدد وجود
المنطقه باسرها وقمه الايجاد تقر خطه لحل
الازمه من ثلاث نقاط ونائب رئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني يقول للجزيره ان
المبادره تتضمن لقاء بين البرهان وحميتي
خلال اسبوعين
اسرائيل تبلغ اداره بايدن نيتها الاعلان
خلال الشهر الحالي عن بناء 4000 وحده
استيطانيه في الضفه الغربيه المعتله البيت
الابيض يجدد رفضه لاي خطوات اسرائيليه
تزيد التوتر وتصعب الوصول الى حل الدولتين
والسلطه الفلسطينيه تطالب المجتمع الدولي
بتحرك حقيقي لمنع تقسيم الضفه الغربيه عبر
مخطط اي واحد الاستيطاني
[موسيقى]
في تطورات جبهات القتال في اوكرانيا موسكو
تقول انها صدت هجمات في مناطق تؤكد كييف
تحقيق مكاسب فيها والجيش الاوكراني يعلن
استعاده بلدات جديده في الجبهات الشرقيه
والجنوبيه بلينكين يعرب عن امله في نجاح
الهجوم المضاد لاوكرانيا لارغام بوتين على
التفاوض وقمه فرنسيه المانيه بولنديه لبحث
مساعده كياف عسكريا وانسانيا
في اول تحذير من نوعه من الامم المتحده
غوتيرش يشدد على ان مخاطر الذكاء
الاصطناعي تمثل تهديدا وجوديا للبشريه
يساوي خطر الحرب النوويه واداره بايدن
تطلب رسميا العوده لليونسكو لمنع الصين من
الانفراد بصيغه القواعد المرتبطه بالذكاء
الاصطناعي
في لقائنا اليومي المعتاد قبل الحصاد كنا
قد ناقشنا معكم توصل الهيئه الحكوميه
للتنميه لايجاد الى مبادره لحلحله الازمه
السودانيه تتضمن 3 نقاط وكذلك تحذير رئيس
مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي من حرب اهليه
السودان اذا لم يتوقف القتال فورا استطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم ما هي فرص
التوصل الى وقف المستدام لاطلاق النار عبر
صيغه افريقيه هذه المره 30% قالوا ان
الفرصه كبيره وعشرون في المئه راوا انها
فرص محدوده بينما خمسه وخمسون في المئه
قالوا انه لا فرص اطلاقا
[موسيقى]
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه تجدد يوميا
تطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعل عربيا
وكذلك دوليا
اذا قال الرئيس الكيني ويلي ان الايغا
توصلت الى مبادره لحلحله الازمه السودانيه
تتضمن ثلاث نقاط بينها تشكيل وفد نيابه عن
الايجاد يضم رؤساء جنوب السودان وكينيا
واثيوبيا وجيبوتي للقاء رئيس مجلس السياده
عبد الفتاح البرهان كما يبحث الوفد خلال
الاسبوعين القادمين مع البرهان وحميتي فتح
ممرات انسانيه وتنص المبادره ايضا على ان
هيئه ايجاد ستشرع خلال ثلاثه اسابيع في
تشكيل لجنه حوار وطني تبدا عملها لفتح
مجال للقاء او للقوى المدنيه في السودان
لمناقشه القضايا العالقه تقرير فوزي بشرى
شهراني الا اياما لم يعرف خلالها القتال
في العاصمه السودانيه توقفا الا في ظل هدن
ما اكثر ما تم خلقها من قبل اطراف الحرب
وهم الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
التي يصفها بالمتمرده ويقول الجيش
السوداني انه يواصل ما قال انها عمليات
تمشيط وتتبع لعناصر القوات الدعم السريع
في مدن العاصمه الثلاث الخرطوم والخرطوم
بحري واندرمان وهي عمليه يكتنفها كثير من
الحذر المؤدي الى البطء في انجازها بسبب
تحرك قوات الدعم السريع وسط الاحياء وسرعه
التحركها بين الامكنه على سيارات الدفع
الرباعي وقد لجات اخيرا وفق الجيش الى
التمويه عن طريق استعمال السيارات المدنيه
المنهوبه من المواطنين ما افوق هذا القتال
وما منطق الاستمرار فيه
قوات الدعم السريع لا تتردد في القول انها
تقاتل من اجل استعاده المسار الديمقراطي
وتاسيس الحكم المدني وهو زعم يسكت حتى
اصحاب المقولات الديمقراطيه عن تعزيزه
بتاكيدهم
فقط لاذ اكثرهم بالصمت او لزوم شعار لا
للحرب والحروب عاده لا تطلبها الجيوش او
الشعوب دفعا لسام الحياه انها تنشا لاسباب
موضوعيه وواقعه الحرب السودانيه انها حرب
نشات ظروفها وحيثياتها تحت بصر القوه
المدنيه والعسكريه سواء بسواء وذلك
بتغاضيها بحسب كثير من السودانيين عن
ظاهره النمو المتسارع لقوات الدعم السريع
ليس ذلك فحسب بل تعاظم النفوذ السياسي
لقائدها الفريق محمد حمدان دقلو نفوذ بوهه
منصبا نائب رئيس مجلس السياده وجعله يتراس
لجنه لمعالجه الوضع الاقتصادي بعد الثوره
كان عبد الله حمدوك رئيس الحكومه المدنيه
الاولى مجرد عضو فيها وهو الخبير
الاقتصادي الذي جيء به الى رئاسه الوزاره
لهذه الميزه لا لغيرها ولم يكن حمدوك اقل
من الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان حماسه
وبلاغه في تزيين شراكه المدنيين والعسكر
واصفا ذلك بالنموذج الملهم الذي يهديه
السودان للاقليم كذلك كان البرهان يفعل في
مدح علاقه الجيش بالدعم السريع حتى لكنهما
توامان لا ينفصلان ولا تقوموا حياه احدهما
بغير الاخر الحرب بينت ان ذلك كان وهما
اما القوى المدنيه في تكويناتها الحزبيه
والمهنيه فقط اتهمت بالانصراف الى هدر
الطاقاتها السياسيه في المنافسه على مغانم
ما بعد سقوط البشير وانها عجزت عن لزوم
مبدئيه شعاراتها في الحريه والسلام
والعداله حتى انتهى الام العسكر الى اللعب
على تناقضاتها التكتيكيه واشتداد عراكها
على مورد السلطه وذلك بتقريب هذا الفريق
مره ثم رميه في العرائس السياسي بتقريب
منافسه وكانت كتله الحريه والتغيير مسرحا
لهذه الملهات السياسيه وحده الفريق كان
يعرف ما يريد وهو بناء قوه عسكريه وماليه
تكون وسيلته الى السلطه التي لا يعدم من
يناصره على حيازتها في الداخل خدمه لطموحه
وخدمه لاجنده الداعمين الخارجيين وكل هذا
كان يجري تحت مقوله التحول الديمقراطي
المفخخه من داخلها في جيبوتي كانت الحرب
السودانيه محلا لتداول رؤساء منظمه ايجاد
من اجل سعي يوقف الحرب ويجمع اطرافها
للتفاوض ذلك كان ايضا هم اعضاء اللجنه
الثلاثيه المكونه من رؤساء جنوب السودان
وكينيا وجيب بتفوض من الاتحاد الافريقي
لوقف الحرب بجهد افريقي خالص يقول الاتحاد
ان من شانه تجنيب السودان تعقيدات
التدخلات الخارجيه لكن مقاربات الاتحاد
الافريقي وكذلك منظمه ايجاد للحرب في
السودان قد تصطدم بتعقيدات توصيفها للصراع
الذي تراه حربا بين جيشين وبين جنرالين
وليس حربا بين الدوله السودانيه وبين قوه
عسكريه تمردت عليها كما يقول الجيش ولذلك
يبدو لكثيرين ان نجاح مبادره الايجاد او
اي مبادره او مقاربه اخرى سيكون رهينا
بمدى قدره هذه المقاربات والمبادرات على
وصف الصراع والنفاذ الى جوهري وجوهره يكمن
في تعريف اطراف الصراع من هم وهذا امر لا
مهرب منه في حرب بدت الكثيرين رغم
ماساويتها ضروريه لانهاء التناقضات ان لم
يصر الى انهائها اليوم رحلت الى الغد
والغدر السودانيين الذين مسهم شر الحرب هو
في تصور سوداني جديد لا يشبه ما كان قبله
في شيء تلك هي عظه الحرب
ترحب بضيفي الى هنا في الاستوديو سيد مزمل
ابو القاسم الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
السوداني اهلا بك
تقرير الزميل فوزي قبل قليل عن كيف وجدت
مخرجات اجتماع الايجاد من اليات طبعا
السؤال عن امكانيه ان يحدث تغيير هذه
الخطه او هذه المقاربه
بكل تاكيد تعتبر منظمه الايجارات نفسها
المعني الاول بهذه الازمه على اعتبارنا
السوداني يمثل احد اهم اعضاء هذه الهيئه
التي المكونه من ثمانيه الدول من دول
الشرق وسط الافريقي هي محاوله لاستعاده
هذا الملف
لتتم ادارته تحت مظله الايجارات واعادته
الى داخل البيت الافريقي تبقى المعضله في
كيفيه الوصول الى الاهداف التي تم الحديث
عنها
وترخصت في ايقاف فوري باطلاق النار هذه
معضله لم يستطيع منبر جده ان يجد حلا لها
عبر عشر هدى تم تشهد اي التزام
بوقف اطلاق النار ايضا تحدثت عن اطلاق
عمليه
بالمساعدات الانسانيه هذه ايضا مع ضلال لم
يستطيع منبر جده يجد لها حلا على اختبارنا
كميه المساعدات الانسانيه سابت للسودان
حتى اللحظه ضعيفه جدا ولم تسهم في اقاله
عشره ملايين سكان الذين هربوا من جحيم
القتال في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم الى
مدن محيطه بالعاصمه ايضا اهم ما رشح عن
هذه المبادره ما تردد عن سعي لجمع البرهان
وحمايه خلال اسبوعين هذه ايضا مع ضلال لا
ندري كيف سيتم حلها في ظل احتجاب فريق
حميتي عن المشهد لاكثر من شهر لم يتحدث
فيه ولم يلتقي او لم يتواصل فيه مع كل
الجهات الدوليه التي تشكيل سيد مزمل رغم
اقرارك بان هذه المجموعه من الحيويه وين
من التاثير بحكم انها افريقيه بحكم انها
دول جوار مع السودان ومع ذلك وهناك نوع من
التشكيك ان يتم تحقيق اهداف هذه الخطه
وليس تشكيك النور هي تساؤلات منطقيه من
خلال ما نشهده على الساحه التي تشهد
ازدحاما شديدا في المبادرات هناك مبادره
للايجار
تم الاعلان عن تفاصيلها اليوم هناك مبادره
اصلا يجري العمل عليها في منبر جده برعايه
سعوديه امريكيه هناك لجنه اتصال دوليه تم
الاتفاق عليها بمشاركه الاليه الثلاثيه
والرباعيه فيها الامم المتحده والاتحاد
الافريقي وعدد من الدول على راسها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والامارات العربيه المتحده
يعني اربعه دول كانت في الاصل منخرطه في
محاوله
ايجاد حل للازمه السودانيه ولكن مساعيها
الت الى حرب دروس اندلعت في العاصمه
الخرطوم وعدد من مدن الولايات طيب ماذا عن
مساله تحديد الاسماء في اي خارطه عمل يتم
تنفيذها تسميه هذا الطرف ماذا يكون من
الازمه وتسميه الطرف الاخر وهذا مطلب تقدم
به السيد البرهان قبل مده حتى الاجتماع
الاتحاد الافريقي وطلب به حتى في جمله
اللقاءات الدوليه تحديد كل طرف بالمسمى
الذي يمثله
هناك تنازع في هذه القضيه على اعتبار ان
الحكومه السودانيه طالبت من خلال المنبر
جده يعني يتم التفاوض تحت لافته الدوله
السودانيه الحكومه السودانيه
وطالبت بان يتم تصنيف ما يحدث داخل
السودان او توصيفه على انه تمرد ذلك لم
يتم وفي النهايه قبل السودان ان يتم
التفاوض مع الدعم السريع تحتلفه الجيش هذا
الامر اثار عاصفه من الانتقادات داخل
السودان الملكي الامر ان كل ما يتردد او
ما يتحدث عنه منظمه الايجاد تم طرحه مسبقا
في منبر جده عبر المبادره السعوديه
الامريكيه ولم يتم ايجاد حلول له لذلك
يبقى السؤال موضوعيا او الاسئله المسارع
حول مدى قدره هذه المبادره على اياد حل
المعضله الانيه مطروحا وموضوعيا كيف سيتم
جمع الفرقاء كيف سيتم التوصل الى وقف
شعامل لاطلاق النار مزمل ابو القاسم
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني شكرا
جزيلا لك
كشف نائب رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني مالك
عقار ان هيئه الايجاد اقترحت لقاءا بين
رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهان وقائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان حميتي ويجري الترتيب لعقده بعد
اسبوعين في احدى دول الايجاد وشدد عقار في
تصريح للجزيره على ان الخلافات لا تنتهي
الا من خلال التفاوض كما قال
في يعني لقاء بين بين الطرفين
رئيس مجلس السياده الفريق اول
وبين قائد قوات الدعم السريه لاتفاق على
وقفه الادعيات والقضايا الانسانيه وقضايا
والقضايا التي ادت الى الحرب
وقال مالك عقار للجزيره ان العمل جاري
لايقاف الحرب والعوده الى طاوله المفاوضات
واكد ان الاولويه الان تتمثل في ضروره
وجود جيش واحد تحت قياده واحده حسب قوله
نحن يعني بنعمل بانه هذا الحرب يقيف
والناس يرجعوا الى طاوله
التفاوض لمعالجه القضايا الملحه التي ادت
الى الى هذا الحرب ولمعالجه القضيه
السوداء السودانيه فيما بعد ذلك لكن نحن
دايرين نوقف الحرب ونعالج القضيه الانيه
التي ادت الى الحرب بحيث انه القضيه التي
عدت الى حرب تكون هنالك في السودان جيش
واحد موحد تحت قياده واحده
رفض نائب رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني مالك
عقار تشبيكه ما يجري في السودان بالحرب
الاهليه مؤكدا في تصريحات للجزيره رفض
بلاده لاي تدخل خارجي
لكن هي ليست حرب اهليه وتدخل الجهات
الخارجيه لا نسمح باي تدخل من الجهات
الخارجيه لانه دي حرب في السودان بين
القوه وبين قوتين القوات الصديقه والقوات
الوطنيه القوات الوطنيه والقوات الصديقه
دي الحرب بينهم فنحن ما بنسمع بدخول اي
طرف من الاطراف سواء كانت
او خارج الاقليم الافريقي بان تدخل في
[موسيقى]
نقل موقع اكسيوس عن مسؤولين اسرائيليين
وامريكيين ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه ابلغت
اداره بايدن انها تعتزم الاعلان في وقت
لاحق من هذا الشهر عن بناء وتخطيط الاف
الوحدات السكنيه الجديده في المستوطنات
بالضفه الغربيه المحتله واشار الموقع الى
ان اداره بايدن تضغط على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لعدم المضي قدما في اعلان
الخطط الاستيطانيه او تقليلها قدر الامكان
ونقلت اكسيوس عن المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن
القومي بالبيت الابيض نواشنطن كانت واضحه
في ان زياده النشاط الاستيطاني تشكل عقبه
امام السلام وتحقيق حل الدولتين
من جانبه طالب رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني
محمد الشيب بضغط دولي حقيقي لوقف تنفيذ
اسرائيل المخططه الاستيطاني الذي بات يعرف
بالمنطقه اي واحد وما يترتب على ذلك من
تقسيم للضفه الغربيه الى منطقتين منفصلتين
مجلس الوزراء من جانب اخر يطالب بضغط دولي
حقيقي لوقف تنفيذ اسرائيل المخطط
الاستيطاني التي الذي بات يعرف بمنطقه اي
1 والذي يهدف الى تقويض فرص اقامه دوله
فلسطين
المتواصله الاطراف من خلال بناء مستعمره
جديده تربط مستعمرات القدس بمستعمرات
معاليه ادميم وما سيترتب على ذلك من تقسيم
للضفه الغربيه الى منطقتين منفصلتين مما
يعني منع حل الدولتين
ويذهب اليها من الناصره ايهاب جبارين
الباحث المختص في شؤون الاسرائيلي سيد
ايهاب اهلا بك رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني
يطالب بضغط دولي كثيف على الجانب
الاسرائيلي لايقاف هذه المخططات هل معنى
ذلك ان الموقف الامريكي لم يعد مؤثرا وهو
يرفض هذه الخطوات او يدعو للتقليل منها
اللي كان يفهم الصور بشكل اوضح ربما يجب
ان ناخذ او نستدرك استراتيجيه ابنه مسك في
السوبر ماركت اما ان تحصل على الشوكولا
واما ان تقلب الدنيا راسا على عقب وهذا
تماما ما تقوم به اسرائيل في هذه المرحله
يعني امام كل الشوشره والضجيج الاعلامي
الذي تقوم به بشان حرب شامله اقليميه
شامله متعدده الجبهات في الشرق الاوسط
والاحتدام مع ايران والقنبله النوويه
الايرانيه وما الى ذلك
وفي ظل كل ذلك هي تحاول ان تقيم ابتزازات
على ارض الواقع على حساب القضيه
الفلسطينيه ومن اهم يعني او ابرزها بدون
ادنى شك هو قضايا الاستيطان في شهر يناير
الاخير هي قد صادقت على 9000 وحده
استيطانيه هذه المره تاتي مع اربعه الاف
وحده استيطانيه
يعني ربما تحاول استلطاف الاداره
الامريكيه بمعنى كهذا او كاخه لكنها قطعا
نتنياهو يحاول ان يستغل ضعف الموقف
الامريكي في ظل كل هذه الازمه الاداره
الامريكيه الاقليميه
يعني ابتزازها بهذه الاربعه الاف وحده
استيطانيه واضف الى ذلك لكن يعني محاوله
التلطيف لربما هي انه وكانه يصوغ وكانه
مخطط
يعني لن يكون ضمن هذه الاربعه الاف وحده
استيطانيه ربما سوف يقوم يعني التفاوض
عليه فيما بعد او الحديث عنه فيما بعد
بكلمات بعد ذلك ان هذا الاسلوب من قبل
حكومه نتنياهو لابتزاز اكثر لهذه الاداره
الامريكيه حتى في موضوعات اخرى وليس ان
نتنياهو
رهينه لائتلافه الحكومي وبالتالي لا
يستطيع ان يقول لا او يقف دون مخططات هذا
اليمين المتطرف في حكومته
هذه نقطه اخرى وهي الاهم بنظري كذلك التي
لا يجب ان نتجاوز عنها النقطه الاخرى التي
يحاول ان يسوقها للاداره الامريكيه لحظه
لدي هنا ائتلاف يميني متشدد انا يجب ان
ادير هذا الائتلاف انا في ازمه لم يعني
لكن لم يكن هنالك لدي ايه حلول اخرى
لاقامه على ارض الواقع فبالتالي هذا اقل
القليل الذي يمكنني ان اقدمه لهذا
الائتلاف انا بابتزازات سياسيه في الداخل
وبالمقابل يعني هنا يجب ان نلاحظ ان في
ذات الوقت كل قضايا التعديلات القضائيه
والامور الاخرى التي لربما غير راضي عنها
الاداره الامريكيه نتنياهو وضعها نوعا ما
جانبا حاليا في هذه الفتره بل بالكلمات
ادق داخليا نتنياهو يحاول النزول عن شجره
التعديلات القضائيه فبالتالي نعم هو يحاول
ان يسوق انني انا باستطاعته ومضور ان ادير
عفوا
هذا الائتلاف لكن بالمقابل هنالك داخلي
انا يجب ان ادفعه هذا الثمن بدون ان نشاك
لدي هنا ائتلاف استيطاني هذا اقل القليل
الذي يمكنني ان اقدمه لدي لديه 4000 وحده
استطانيه
ويعني ربما سوف اتجاوز عن امور شائكه في
هذه المرحله هذا اقل من قليل طيب اشاره
الجانب الامريكي في التعبير عن موقفه
وربطه بين بان هذه الخطوات من شانها ان
تقضي على مساله او فكره حل الدولتين وكذلك
ما يتعلق بمصير القدس ماذا عن هذه الجزئيه
في الموقف الامريكي في الحسابات
الاسرائيليه هذه المره
يعني بدون مشاكل ان الاداره الامريكيه
واضحه بالنسبه لكل ما يخص كذلك قضيه تجزئه
الضفه الغربيه وهي تعلم جيدا في نهايه
المطاف ما هي نوايا هذا اليمين الاستيطاني
المتطرف الذي يتواجد فيه بل اكثر من ذلك
يجب ان ندرك ان هنالك اداره ما يسمى اداره
التنظيم التي كان قام بانشائها
ضمن وزارته في داخل وزاره الجيش التي يقوم
عن طريقها نوع من تنظيم كل ما يخص
التخطيطات الاستيطانيه
وهذه النقطه مهمه جدا يجب ان ندركها كل
المخططات الاستيطانيه هي يعني القدس وشمال
القدس هي لا تعني بتاتا بجزئيه جنوب القدس
فبالتالي ما تحاول اسرائيل او على الاقل
الاداره الاستيطانيه بالنسبه ان تفرض على
امر الواقع نوعا ما حل او احتلال او ضم
اشكاليه ضم القرد عفوا شمال الضفه ان
تضعها
في المقابل من الناصره ايهاب جبارين
الباحثه المختص في الشؤون الاسرائيليه
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
في اخر تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
قالت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه انها
استعاده السيطره على بلده
في قرب دونيتس وتعد هذه البلده الرابعه
التي تعلن القوات الاوكرانيه استعادتها
منذ امس في المقابل اعلنت قوات الجنوب في
الجيش الروسي انها صدت هجوما اوكرانيا في
اتجاه سوليدار بخموت شمالي دونيت واحبطت
محاوله استطلاع للجيش الاوكراني في
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد يواصل تقدمه وفق
اعلانات اوكرانيه متواليه بتحقيق تقدم
ميداني الدعايه العسكريه الاوكرانيه تنشر
صورا لهجمات نفذتها في
ظهرت فيها مدرعات برادلي الامريكيه مؤكده
ضمنيا على اثر التسليح الغربي ميدانيا كما
يتحدث قاده اوكرانيون وفي نفس الوقت تبقى
عين كياف مصوبه نحو باخمت رغبه في محو
انكساراتها هناك وصولا لاستعاده المدينه
يؤكد الجيش الاوكراني تحقيق تقدم في جبهه
بخموت لكن التطور الاحدث كان اعلان وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه استعاده السيطره على
بلدات عديده في مقاطعه
ابرزها مدينه ستورجوف في مقاطعه
الاركان الاوكرانيه انها صدت هجوما روسيا
في منطقه
في المقابل اعلنت قوات الجنوب بالجيش
الروسي صد هجوم اوكراني على محور السوليد
ار بخموت واحباط محاوله اوكرانيه لاجراء
استطلاع باتجاه
بمقاطعه لوجانسك
بالانتقال قرب مدينه زابورجيا يعلن الجيش
الاوكراني مواصله الهجوم على محور
تارنيسكفا الى الجنوب الشرقي حيث احدى
نقاط القتال الساخنه وفي جبهه خرسون يتحدث
الاوكرانيون عن انخفاض كثافه القصف بعد
تراجع القوات الروسيه جراء تفجير سد
كاخوكا
[موسيقى]
اليوم الماضي انخفضت كثافه القصف على
خرسون والضفه اليمنى لنهر نيبر الى حد ما
قصف العدو تسع مرات النهار امس و19 مره
خلال الليل تتحدث هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
ايضا عن عشرات الغارات الروسيه والهجمات
الصاروخيه على اكثر من جبهه مقابل غارات
وضربات صاروخيه استهدفت مواقع روسيه على
طول الجبهه الشرقيه وفي يوميات الحرب
المتطاوله يقدم الجانب الروسي روايته ايضا
القوات المواليه لموسكو تنشر صورا لتدمير
مدرعه امريكيه من طراز اوشكوش ام اي تي في
قرب بلده بلاجو داتوني جنوبيه مقاطعه تظهر
الصور توجيه مسيره انتحاريه روسيه من طراز
لاندست لاستهداف مدرعه تابعه للجيش
الاوكراني معارك محتدمه وبيانات لا تتوقف
من طرفي القتال وصيف جديد تدخله الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا قد يدور سؤاله
الابرز عما عنه ما تصفه بالهجوم المضاد
هذا وقال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ان اي
اتفاق سلام في اوكرانيا يجب ان يحترم
ميثاق الامم المتحده بما يعني احترام
السياده والوحده الترابيه للدول واضاف ان
هذا السلام يجب ان لا يكون من النوع الذي
يسمح لروسيا بالتقاط الانفاس لتعود للهجوم
بعد سته اشهر او سنه او سنتين
ان نجاح اوكرانيا في الهجوم المضاد سيحقق
هدفين سيقوي موقف اوكرانيا في اي مفاوضات
انحصلت ويمكن ان يكون له التاثير الذي
يدفع بوتين الى التركيز على المفاوضات
والعمل على انهاء الحرب التي بداها
معنى من عمان لواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري اهلا بك لواء فايز امام هذه
البيانات المتضاربه من تاكيد الهجوم
وتاكيد صد الهجوم متى يمكننا التاكد من
وجود تغير حقيقي في الجغرافيا بالنسبه
لهذا الطرف او ذاك
يعني كما اشرت هناك تعارضات واضحه جدا حول
ما يجري هناك ضبابيه هناك يبدو شحف
المعلومات او عدم الرغبه بالافصاح من قبل
الجانب الاوكراني ولكن في بعد اربعه ايام
من بدء الهجوم او المرحله التحضيريه
للهجوم انجاز التعبير لانه لا يمكن ان
يكون هذا هو الهجوم الذي تم الحديث عنه
لعده اشهر لماذا لان حجم القوات المشاركه
في هذه العمليات لا يرقى الى مستوى الهجوم
المضاد لكن خلال الاربعه ايام الماضيه
نتائجها تشير او تعطي دلالات عامه عن
اتجاهات المعركه القادمه نعم هناك نجاحات
تم السيطره على اربعه بلدات خلال الساعات
الماضيه 24 ساعه الماضيه ثمن بلدات
بالمطلق لكن اذا نظرنا الى الخارطه نجدها
تتركز في منطقه دونسك
والالتقاء حدود دونيسك مع زابولوجيا
وبالتالي هذه تعطي مؤشر عن اتجاه العمليات
القادمه اذا ما نجحت هذه العمليات واكملت
الدوره العملياتيه بالسيطره على المناطق
الحاسمه والاراضي التعبويه لانه لهذه
المعارك تفتح امام القوات الاوكرانيه في
حال اكمال المرحله الاولى ثلاثه اتجاهات
للعمل
تختار الانسب والاقدر على تحقيقه اما ان
تكون باتجاه ماريوبل وهذه المسافه تقريبا
تحتاج 94 كيلو متر اما ان تتجه باتجاه
بلوتوبل
توكماك ميليتوبل او اتجاه بحر اوسوف الى
المنطقه
الى المنطقه بين ميليتوبل وماريوبل
وبالتالي حتى هذه اللحظه نعم هناك نجاحات
ولكن ليست النجاحات التي كانت متوقعه هناك
نجاحات روسيه في الحاق خسائر واعاقه
الهجوم في اكثر من نقطه طيب هذا يجر لي
السؤال عن ان كان ما يجري الان هو فعلا
انطلاق للهجوم للمضاد الذي تم الاعلان عنه
قبل فتره او كما توقعت وحللت حضرتك حضره
اللواء فايز بانه مقدمه للهجوم ما الذي
اختلف في ايقاع العمليات حتى الان حتى يتم
تحديد ان كان هذا هو الهجوم المضاد او
مقدمه لهذا الهجوم
يعني الان حجم الهجوم حجم القوات المشاركه
كما قلت لك هناك ضبابيه وشحف المعلومه لكن
قبل تقريبا
48 ساعه تحدث وزير الدفاع الروسي وتحدث عن
هجوم بحجم لواء هذه المعلومات التي اتت من
وزير الدفاع شويجو قال بحجم لواء هذا
الحجم من القوات استنادا الى تصريح وزير
الدفاع تعتبر قوات صغيره جدا نفذت عمليات
تسمى استطلاع بالقوه لتحديد نقاط الضعف
واحداث اختراقات من اجل تسهيل الهجوم
الرئيسي لا يعقل ان ولكن دعني اقول ان حتى
هذه التقديرات هي اقل من الواقع لابد ان
يكون الهجوم اكثر من ذلك لكن انا اتحدث
بما عدلا به وزير الدفاع بينما الجانب
الاوكراني لا يزال متكتم حول طبيعه
العمليه فقط يعطي ايماحا انه تم السيطره
على هذه البلده وعلى تلك البلده من عمان
اللواء فايز الدويري العسكري والاستراتيجي
شكرا جزيلا لك
قال الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون في
مؤتمر صحفي مع المستشار الالماني او
لافولتس والرئيس البولنديه اندري دودا ان
الدول الثلاث فعلت او فعلت كل شيء لمساعده
الهجوم المضاد واضاف انه تم تكثيف تسليم
الذخائر والاسلحه والعربات وان ذلك
سيتواصل في الايام والاسابيع القادمه
واستقبل الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرو
المستشار الالماني والرئيس الفولندي في
باريس في قمه حول تقديم المساعده
لاوكرانيا ويعمل القاده الثلاثه على
المساعده العسكريه والانسانيه ضمن ما يسمى
مثلث فايمار وهو اطار سياسي يضم ممثلين عن
المانيا وفرنسا وفولندا
وغير بعيد عن الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
بدات في المانيا اكبر مناورات جويه في
تاريخ النيتو منذ تاسيسه وبدا النيتو في
قاعده بونستروف شماليه المانيا مناورات
الدفاع الجوي 23 التي اطلقت فكرتها عام
2018 في اطار الرد على ضم روسيا شبه جزيره
القرم في العام 2014
لاحقا في فقره المتابعه الضوء بمزيد من
التفصيل على مناورات النيتو ونسال ضيف
الحصاد عن الرسائل والتوقيت والاهداف من
هذه المناورات
[موسيقى]
الى ملف شائك يثير مخاوف واسئله كبيره
بشان مستقبل البشريه ففي اول تحذير من
نوعه قال الامين العام للامم المتحده
ان تحذيرات العلماء تؤكد ان تهديدات
الذكاء الاصطناعي لا تقل خطوره عن الحروب
النوويه
وطالب غوتيرج المجتمع الدولي باخذ هذه
التحذيرات على محمل الجد وفق تعبيره
التكنولوجيا الحديثه تتحرك بسرعه كبيره
وكذلك التهديدات التي تصاحبها اجراس
الانذار حول احدث اشكال الذكاء الاصطناعي
او الذكاء الاصطناعي التوليدي تصم الاذان
واولئك الذين صمموه يقرعون الاجراس باعلى
صوت هؤلاء العلماء والخبراء دعوا العالم
الى التحرك واعلنوا ان الذكاء الاصطناعي
يمثل تهديدا وجوديا للبشريه يساوي خطر
الحرب النوويه يجب ان ناخذ تلك التحذيرات
على محمل الجد
وارتباطا بذلك عدد الولايات الات نظمته
اليونسكو ان الولايات المتحده طلبت العوده
الى المنظمه التي غادرتها في فتره الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب وسيخضع الطلب
الامريكي لتصويت سري ونقلت بلومبرغ عن
مسؤولين امريكيين قولهم ان قرار العوده
الى منظمه اليونسكو مدفوع بالقلق بالاتساع
دور الصين في سياسات المنظمه لا سيما وضع
معايير عالميه لاستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي
ولكن لماذا كل هذه التخوفات من الذكاء
الاصطناعي ما هي المخاطر التي يواجهها
البشر التي تخضع هذه التكنولوجيا على درجه
متساويه من الخطر النووي في هذا التقرير
نحاول ان نقربكم من هذه المخاطر فهل
نستطيع التمييز بين الاله والانسان فيه
الذكاء الصناعي يمكن ان يكون خطيرا مثل
القنبله النوويه العديد من العلماء يقلقون
من امكانيه تطور الذكاء الصناعي ليكون
واعيا ما قد يؤدي الى تحديات غير متوقعه
وغير قابله للسيطره اذا وصلت هذه الانظمه
الى هذه الحاله قد تكون قادره على اتخاذ
قراراتها الخاصه والعمل بشكل مستقل ورغم
ان التطورات الحاليه في مجال الذكاء
الصناعي تمثل فرصا هائله للتقدم لكنها
تحمل ايضا العديد من المخاطر المحتمله
التي يجب ان ننظر فيها بعنايه العلماء
والفلاسفه يناقشون مخاطر عده قد تنتج عن
استخدام وتطور الذكاء الصناعي منها توفير
المعلومات بسرعه وكميات تفوق قدره الانسان
وهو ما قد يستخدم في نشر الاخبار الزائفه
والمضلله
الذكاء الصناعي قد يسبب اضرارا كبيره اذا
لم يتم التحكم فيه بشكل صحيح يمكن ان يؤدي
تطور الذكاء الصناعي الى استبدال البشر في
العديد من الوظائف ما يزيد من معدلات
البطاله
قد تستخدم الحكومات الذكاء الصناعي ضد
مواطنيها سواء للرقابه او التلاعب بالراي
العام او لاي غرض اخر يتعارض مع حقوق
الانسان الطائرات بدون طيار والاسلحه
الذكيه من الجيل السادس قد تستخدم في
النزاعات المسلحه وقد تكون خارج نطاق
الرقابه الانسانيه ما يزيد من مخاطر
الاخطاء والاضرار الجانبيه
ولتعلموا لماذا تاتي هذه التحذيرات بشكل
متسارع من كل حدب وصوب كانت اخطار الذكاء
الصناعي المذكوره في التقرير مصوغه من قبل
الذكاء الصناعي ذاته بعد ان اعطيناه
التعليمات والاوامر المطلوبه فصاغا هذا
الجزء من التقرير هل شعرتم بالفرق بين
صياغه الانسان والاله ان التخوفات من
تكامل عناصر التهديد هذه تتزايد يوما بعد
يوم فوصول للذكاء الصناعي لحاله الوعي قد
تمكنه من اعطاء الاوامر لنفسه خروجه عن
السيطره ومن ثم البحث عن المعلومات وتعلم
كيفيه الوصول الى ما يحتاج عبر الانترنت
ومن ثم وصوله الى قدره التحكم بالاسلحه
الذكيه واختراقه لانظمه الحمايه عندها
تصبح الاحتمالات والسيناريوهات ممكنه
معنا من بيجين رونج روان الاعلامي والباحث
السياسي ومن واشنطن الدكتور ديفيد سيدني
نائب مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق
لشؤون الامن القومي في اسيا ونائب رئيس
البعثه الامريكيه في الصين سابقا اهلا بكم
وابدا بضيف من واشنطن
لاساله عن هذه
المخاوف الامريكيه مما يتعلق بالصين فيما
يتعلق بالمجال الذكاء الاصطناعي والتي دعت
الى واشنطن بالعوده او طلب العوده سريعا
الى منظمه اليونسكو ما طبيعه هذه
المخاوف لدى الجانب الامريكي
الحقيقه هذه المخاوف مرتبطه باستخدام ذكاء
الاصطناعي والاشراف على الذكاء الاصطناعي
وهو من بين التحديات التي تواجهها كل
البلدان ولكن على وجه الخصوص الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والصين ونتحدث عن بلدين
لديهما تقدم كبير في مجال التكنولوجيات
والذكاء الاصطناعي ويوم امس
وهو رئيس اوبن اي اي وهي الشركه التي اسست
تشاد
واذا قالوا انهم يبحثون عن تعاون مع الصين
بالنسبه الى رقبه على الذكاء الاصطناعي في
اليونسكو هناك تحركات لوضع المعايير
بالنسبه الى الذكاء الاصطناعي الولايات
المتحده خرجت تقريبا منذ اكثر من 7 سنوات
ولذلك لم تشارك الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في جهود وضع المعايير لذلك
اعلنت عن ني اتها العوده الى اليونسكو من
اجل تاديه دور اضافي بالنسبه الى هذه
الجهود ولكن ما الذي تخشاه وابقى معك
دكتور ديفيد ما الذي تخشاه واشنطن
بالتحديد حتى الان من يملك الرياده في هذا
المجال هي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وليس الصين ما الذي تخشاه بالتحديد
مبعث القلق الامريكي في هذا الخصوص هو
تنافس في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي والذي
يمكن ان يؤدي الى استخدام الذكاء
الاصطناعي بطريقه سيئه ليس فقط في الصين
والولايات المتحده بل لكل انحاء العالم
هناك حاجه لكي تتضافر الجهود على المستوى
الدولي لمواجهه التبعات السلبيه التي
اشرتم الى بعضها المرتبطه بذكاء الاصطناعي
هذا يتم من خلال التعاون على مستوى
اليونسكو وايضا على مستوى ثنائي بين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والصين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لديها تقدم
كبير في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي بقياده عدد
كبير من الشركات ولكن الصين كذلك لديها
جهود رياديه مدعومه من الحكومه الصينيه ان
المخاطر وكما اشار الامين العام السيد
غوتيرش قال
المخاطر تتهدد الانسانيه برمتها لذلك يجب
ان نرى تازرا للجهود مواجهه هذه المخاطر
ضيفي من بيجين بعض المخاوف المعبر عنها من
قبل الاصوات في الغرب من مشروع الذكاء
الصناعي في الصين انه ربما قاعده البيانات
التقنيه لدى الصين قد تكون اوسع لعدم وجود
نفس الضوابط التي توجد في الدول الغربيه
كالولايات المتحده وغيرها وبالتالي يمكن
استعمال الذكاء الصناعي بشكل اوسع لانه
ليس هناك ضوابط وبالتالي ما هو ردكم على
هذه المخاوف الغربيه
اهلا ومرحبا بكم
اولا
يعني قد استثمارات يعني مبادئ مبادئ
وحائله في التدوير القطعه في الذكاء
الاصطناعي وحصل على كذلك التقدم في هذا
المجال
ولكن هناك ايضا
التاثيرات السلبيه المحتمله في هذا الذكر
اصطناعي
ومثل الانتحاك للخصوصيات البشر وكذلك يعني
المخاطر امنيه وكذلك يعني فيما يتعلق
بالبطاله وكذلك يعني احتكار
وكذلك يعني التاثيرات السلبيه على
يعني البشر
ولذلك الصين ايضا تعمل على يعني وضع
القوانين
مراقبه لقيام المراقبه
فيما يتعلق بالذكر الاصطناعي وتشديد يعني
مراقبتها على كذلك على ما يتعلق
بالملكيه الفكريه او مشاكل الاخرى
المحتمله الناجمه منها
الذكاء الاصطناعي فطبعا نعتبر هذا ايضا
السلاح الحدين
ونقوم بالتدبير هل معنى ذلك واعذرني على
المقاطعه ان الصين ما مدى له السيد غوتيرش
من ايجاد اليه شبيهه
[موسيقى]
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه لمراقبه
الانتشار النووي ان يكون هناك اليه مشابهه
فيما يتعلق بالجانب الخطير من الاستعمال
للذكاء الاصطناعي
تعمل على القوانين واللاوعيحه وضعوا
الانتشار الجانب السلبي للذكاء الاصطناعي
وتقوم بمراقبه هذا
التطور هذا في هذا القطاع
يعني تستفيد من
الايجابياتها ووضع حد
للتاثيرات سلبيات لهذا
الذكاء في هذا القطاع طيب ضيفي من واشنطن
بعض التقديرات تقول بانه غالبا الصين لن
تعارض مساله عوده واشنطن الى اليونسكو هل
هذا يبدي استعدادا صينيا للتعاون فيما
يتعلق بهذه الاليه التي دعا لها سيد غوترج
لمراقبه تطور الذكاء الاصطناعي في العالم
في الحقيقه في البيان اليوم قال السفير
الصيني امورا ايجابيه في طبعا ممثل الصين
قال امورا ايجابيه بالنسبه الى عوده
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى اليونسكو
وهذا ايجابي
ومخاوف التي عبر عنها الامين العام للامم
المتحده يمكن التعامل معها من خلال
الاليات متعدده الاطراف واليونسكو هي جزء
من ذلك امل ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والصين سوف تعملان مع بعضهما لوضع هذه
النظم واللوائح والقوانين والتشريعات للحد
من التبعات السلبيه
للذكاء الاصطناعي ولكن يتعين علينا ان
ننتظر لنرى لان العمل كثير
شكرا لك من واشنطن الدكتور ديفيد سيدني
نائب مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكيه السابق
لشؤون الامن القومي في اسيا ونائب رئيس
البعثه الامريكيه في الصين سابقا وكذلك من
بيجين
الاعلامي والباحث السياسي
[موسيقى]
عوده الى اجواءها توتر بين الغرب وموسط
والتي زادت حدتها منذ بدء روسيا حربها على
اوكرانيا فقد بدا حلف شمال الاطلسي اليوم
اكبر مناوره جويه في تاريخه مرتبطه بنشر
القوات الجويه في اوروبا ماذا في التفاصيل
يظن التدريب
او الدفاع الجوي 23 الذي يستمر عشره ايام
نحو 200 وخمسين طائره عسكريه من 25 دوله
عضو وحليفه لحلف شمال الاطلسي منها
اليابان والسويد المرشحه للانضمام الى
الحلف الدفاعي وسيشارك نحو عشره الاف جندي
في هذه المناورات الهادفه الى تعزيز
التشغيل المشترك والحمايه من المسيرات
وصواريخ كروز في حال وقوع هجوم على مدن او
مطارات او موانئ واقعه ضمن اراضي النيتو
وستشمل المناورات تدريبا عم وتكتيكيا
خصوصا في المانيا وايضا في تشيكيا
واستونيا ولاتفيا
واللافت ان العديد من طياري التحالف
سيعملون معا للمره الاولى خلال التدريبات
ويجري التخطيط لتنفيذ نحو الفيض العجويه
في هذه المناورات التي اطلقت او اطلقت
فكرتها عام 2018 كجزء من الرد على ضم
روسيا شبه جزيره القرم من اوكرانيا وفي
اشاره الى الطبيعه الدفاعيه للحلف
والمناورات قال قائد سلاح الجو الالماني
انه لن ترسل اي طائره باتجاه جيب
كالينغراد على سبيل المثال وهو الجيب
الروسي المحاذي لدولتي بولندا وليتوانيا
العضوين في شمال الاطلسي بطبيعه الحال هذه
التدريبات التي يقودها الجيش الالماني
تجري خلال حرب المحتدمه بين روسيا
واوكرانيا المرشحه المحتمله لعضويه الحلف
عن هذه هذا التوقيت فماذا عن الاهداف
والرسائل من هذه المناورات في اطار كشفها
عن خطط المناورات قالت سفينه الولايات
المتحده لدى المانيا ايمي جوتمان انه
يتعين على الرئيس الروسي ان يلحظ ما يظهره
التدريب الجوي من روحي وقوه حلف الاطلسي
مدير الحرس الجوي الوطني الامريكيه
الجنرال مايكل علق على التدريبات بالقول
ان مهام النيتو عند منعطف والكثير تغير في
المشهد الاستراتيجي حول العالم خصوصا في
اوروبا وتابع بالقول ان المناورات الجويه
تركز على تكميل حضور الولايات المتحده
الدائم في اوروبا وتوفير التدريب على نطاق
اوسع مما يتم تحقيقه عاده في القاره في
تعليقه على المناورات قال قائد سلاح الجو
الالماني جنرال انجو
للتلفزيون العام زيد دي اف ان اهم اشاره
نرسلها هي اننا قادرون على الدفاع عن
انفسنا
المناورات التي ستجري في المجال الجوي
الالماني تهدف بحسب بيانات وتصريحات
متتاليه الى تدريب قوه النيتو على كيفيه
صد هجوم وهمي من قبل معتد شرقي
للمزيد ينضم الينا من بروكسل روبرت
وهو مدير السابق لمكتب معلومات الناتو في
روسيا سيد روبرت لنبدا
بالرسائل واضحه ومعلنه ان هذه المناورات
مرتبطه وموجهه الى موسكو تحديدا ماذا عن
توقيتها الان وطبيعه هذه المناورات
امين نعم انتم على حق نحن نتحدث عن
مناورات هي الاكبر في تاريخ حلف شمال
الاطلسي نتحدث عن 250 طائره
والعدد كبير من الجنود طبعا ليست كل
الطائرات طائرات المقاتله هي طائرات
متعادله المهام ولكن الرساله واضحه للغايه
ان حلف شمال الاطلسي يمكنه يمكنه ان يقوم
بذلك
بالتعاون بين الدول الاعضاء وهناك تعزيز
للقدرات في الدفاعيه بالتعاون مع القوات
البحريه
والبريه
الاهميه الان تاتي بنا الى الحرب الاكبر
في العالم الان لدينا الدوله المعتديه
روسيا التي قامت بعمليه اعتدائيه وحشيه
استهدفت اوكرانيا
وهناك
تجهيزا
لقاذفات روسيه لاستهداف اوكرانيا
والحلفاء على مستوى حلف شمال الاطلسي لا
يمكنهم ان يقبلوا بهذه التهديدات هم بحاجه
للاستجابه هذه هي الرساله ولكن ايضا على
المستوى العملي هذا مهم للغايه ان التنسيق
في مجال العمليات هو في غايه الاهميه وهذا
ما سوف يسلط الضوء عليه
التدريب المشترك لمده اسبوعين هذه
التدريبات
الضوء على التعاون عندما يقول مدير الحرس
الوطني الامريكي ان هذه المناورات هي
تعبير عن منعطف كبير فيما يتعلق
باستراتيجيه الحلف
الاطلسي وان المشهد الاستراتيجي في العالم
قد تغير ما الذي يعنيه بذلك
في الحقيقه بطريقه من الطرق نعم ان الوضع
تغير لان هذه الحرب التي شنتها روسيا طبعا
دعونا لا ننسى ما حصل في العام 2014 بعد
ضم شبه جزيره القرم والاعتداءات الروسيه
على الاجزاء الشرقيه من اوكرانيا ولكنها
المره الثانيه التي تشن فيها روسيا عمليه
مماثله وهذا ادى الى كسر الاعراف الدوليه
واثبتت روسيا انها لا تابى بشان القانون
الدولي هذا هو الوضع على ما هو عليه الان
ومن ناحيه اخرى حلف شمال الاطلسي يقوم
بتدريبات عسكريه دفاعيه حيث ان هذا
التحالف هو دفاعي وبالتالي لدينا تبعات
الحرب في اوكرانيا وهذه التبعات تتخطى
الحدود الاوكرانيه والحدود الاوروبيه
وبالتالي يتعين على حلف شمال الاطلسي ان
يستعد وهذا هو الهدف ولكن الطبيعه هي
طبيعه الدفاعيه هل هناك اي مؤشرات تقول
بان لدى روسيا النيه بان تنفذ عمليات في
دوله هي عضو الناتو حتى يتم اجراء هذه
المناورات الدفاعيه
لا نتحدث عن النيه روسيه هنا حيث ان روسيا
استخدمت
العمليات من قبل
وهناك عدد كبير من عمليات
تسميم التي جرت في دول متعدده باضافه الى
الهجمات السيبرانيه واستخدام الادوات
المختلفه ما الذي يمنع روسيا من الاعتداء
على دول مضويه تحت لواء حلف شمال الاطلسي
انما يمنع روسيا هو جاهزيه حلف شمال
الاطلسي نحن لا يمكننا ان نركن الى
الضمانات التي تقدمها روسيا حيث ان الرئيس
بوتين وقبل بدء العمليه الاعتدائيه على
اوكرانيا بايام قليله كان يستهزئ به
المعلومات التي سلطت الضوء على النيه
الروسيه وبالتالي النظره نحو روسيا هي على
انها مصدر تهديد ولذلك يجب اتخاذ
الاجراءات والمناورات هي جزء من ذلك شكرا
لك ادركنا الوقت من
المدير السابق لمكتب معلومات النيتو في
روسيا
اذا نكون قد وصلنا الى ختام حلحصى لهذا
اليوم الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]